hello good people of the internet it is
wetness day once again so we're gonna
figure out what the heck this guy was
from last week
this is drum roll please this is a great
horned owl owls most species of owl will
have very very hairy feet not really
hairs as we learned last week there
these are actually feathers and the
reason for that is that they you know
they hunt at night and it's kind of cold
and it's nice to have you know wool
socks right one of the really neat
things that we've found through
experiments is that we've been able to
breed that through selective breeding
into chickens and they will grow
feathers instead of scales on their feet
so cool feathers scales very closely
related in birds anyway my neighbors are
mowing the lawn so hope you enjoy
listening to that but this week specimen
is absolutely tiny just a little hint or
maybe this is a non hint this animal may
or may not be tropical it may or may not
live in Australia it may or may not
really like to eat nuts with its sharp
hooked beak and I'm not going to show
you this bird's feet because that was
making it way too easy for everybody
people were getting those last two birds
like right out of the gate and that
ain't cool remember there's no googling
allowed I'm suspicious that either the
people that are playing this game are
all like trained zoologist now or people
started just googling and ignoring the
rules so don't do that just you know be
fair be nice to everybody
what could this little guy be here it is
next to the red-tailed hawk for size
comparison
super cute little guy what do you think
it is what's it Wednesday put your
comments down in the comment section
good luck
what's it Wednesday
why did the turkey cross the road let's
find out
these are wild turkeys in Corvallis
Oregon there's a lot of them in this
neighborhood a lot of people hate them
they're kind of a nuisance because they
walk around like idiots in the road and
they mess up people's gardens and stuff
but I love having giant bipedal
tetrapods in the neighborhood they're
really cool they do stop traffic though
and they just they're not why did the
turkey cross the road it was to peck at
some grass on the other side
mystery solved
this is a female looks like over here
stretching whereas these appear to be
males